[Music]
The Legend of Zelda is one of the most
beloved Series in all of gaming over 30
years it has innovated game design
inspired countless other game developers
and changed the landscape of video games
for good to celebrate the launch of the
eagerly awaited tears of the Kingdom
let's take a look at the history of the
Legend of Zelda
[Music]
in the mid-1980s Shigeru Miyamoto was
working on Super Mario Brothers for the
famicom but began noodling around with
an idea for a different game Miyamoto
was inspired by his youth exploring the
Japanese Countryside and wanted to move
away from the linearity of Mario to give
players an adventure where they had to
carefully consider their next moves the
team worked up a classic Damsel in
distressed Tale whereby the hero link
would rescue Princess Zelda from the
evil ganon's lair on Death Mountain it
was a simple premise but Miyamoto along
with Takashi tazuka went on to build
something on top of it that would change
the kinds of games Nintendo made the
Legend of Zelda and it's really rad
those creatures from Guiana are pretty
bad mimoto's stated goal was to focus on
allowing players to enter a different
world which he described as a Miniature
Garden which as a player looking at a
top-down perspective very much was
realized by The Legend of Zelda the idea
of connecting players to the world was
so important that the hero wrote was
called link to represent the bridge
between the player and Hyrule despite
being the first entry in a franchise
that would go on to exist for many years
to come The Legend of Zelda laid down
very strong foundations both from a
narrative and gameplay perspective
nearly every subsequent game in the
series has featured themes of coming of
age stepping out into the wild unknown
exploring vast worlds building bonds and
saving the world elements such as the
Triforce were introduced in the first
game and have become a core part of the
series and instantly recognizable
iconography within games as a medium and
of course Princess Zelda named after the
wife of novelist F Scott Fitzgerald has
been present in the vast majority of the
games Ganon was introduced as the demon
king and primary antagonist of The
Legend of Zelda and has fulfilled that
role since the first entry in the series
also set out the core tenets of the
Zelda playing experience namely
exploration puzzle solving and battling
through dungeons
all of this was new ground for Nintendo
but it proved to be an unmitigated
success critically it was described as a
groundbreaking game that had an
impressive sense of scale and offered a
thrilling adventure commercially the
game sold over 6 million copies
worldwide and in that time since has
been re-released and made available on
newer platforms The Legend of Zelda
remains one of the most influential
games of all time and was the
springboard for a franchise that would
define Nintendo Legend of Zelda
continues defeat your enemies
released just under a year after the
original game and with a new development
team behind it Zelda 2 The Adventure of
Link was noticeably different in a
number of ways its story features the
same link as the first game but Princess
Zelda is different she's actually the
Princess Zelda from The Legend who had
been put under a sleeping spell after
refusing to spill secrets about the
Triforce outside of the Overworld Zelda
2 was played from a side-scrolling
perspective and it also Incorporated
magic spells instead of items limited
lives and RPG systems like experience
points and leveling its combat was also
more varied most notably including a
down thrust move that would later go on
to inspire the core gameplay of games
such as Shovel Knight and DuckTales
Zelda 2 was praised by critics and fans
for being so different from the original
and while a lot of its gameplay changes
weren't carried forward into other
entries in the franchise a number of its
elements such as the introduction of a
magic system and the concept of Link's
Shadow impacted future games
considerably
[Applause]
[Music]
Icom in 1991 A Link to the Past acts as
a very distant prequel to the other
games and is the first in the hero is
defeated alternate timeline oh yes the
Legend of Zelda has multiple timelines
and for a deep dive into those make sure
to check out our video right here on
Gamespot
A Link to the Past is notable for many
reasons it was a return to the top-down
Viewpoint of the first game and it was
the debut of the franchise's now iconic
Master Sword by collecting three
pendants of virtue link can obtain the
sword from the Lost Woods and use it to
defeat aganim the game didn't just take
place in Hyrule using a magic mirror
link can also travel to a dark world
that was created when Ganon took the
Triforce twisting the light and beauty
of Hyrule and its occupants into creepy
monsters in this realm the game also
features a very fun Easter egg Nintendo
Power Magazine ran a contest where the
winner would appear in an upcoming
undisclosed Nintendo game the winner was
a kid called Chris Hulan and there's a
secret room in the game where you can
find him a link to the past was
critically acclaimed and was re-released
on the Game Boy Advance with multiplayer
title 4 swords in 2002 but unfortunately
they did remove the Easter egg
thank you
after development had finished On A Link
to the Past some members of the team
started fiddling around with the
Nintendo Game Boy after hours to see how
the console worked and to see if they
could Port A Link to the Past to it
throughout the process the team started
to suggest new ideas and features to
implement into the port and it quickly
became apparent that there was enough
there for a new game at the time David
Lynch's TV show Twin Peaks was booming
in popularity and it inspired the team
to create something thematically similar
with a small town full of distinctive
memorable characters Link's Awakening
doesn't feature most of the core tenets
of the original Legend of Zelda there's
no Zelda it doesn't take place in Hyrule
and there's no Triforce in sight instead
link is stranded on an island and
trapped by a mythical sleeping creature
called the wind fish who he needs to
awaken by collecting magical instruments
Shigeru Miyamoto distracted by other
projects the lynx Awakening team
experimented a lot they snuck in cameos
from other games and focused more on
story than previous Zelda titles it paid
off as Not only was it critically and
commercially successful but the emphasis
on storytelling helped shape the Zelda
franchise for years to come
[Music]
Super Mario 64 launched alongside the
Nintendo 64 in 1996 and Nintendo
originally wanted the next Zelda title
Ocarina of Time to launch the following
Christmas or at least that was the plan
Ocarina of Time ended up being a much
more ambitious project than the team
anticipated and on top of all that they
had to get to grips with the new
Hardware's limitations when implementing
combat the team was struggling to figure
out how to make it work as they were
initially inspired by chanbara a
Japanese sword fighting technique where
the sword is held in both hands whereas
link holds a shield in one hand and his
sword in another the other problem was
making it all work in a 3D space so the
team took a field trip to watch some
chanbara at toei Kyoto Studio Park a
film studio meets theme park in a
similar vein to Universal Studios here
in America they noticed the way that
opponents would move and strafe around
each other when squaring off this
inspired them to create Z targeting by
pressing a button the camera shifts to
be directly behind link and all of his
attacks are aimed right to the Target
link can strafe around so that he's
always facing them and to make it clear
which enemy you're targeting the team
made the icon a fairy which koizuma a
developer on the team called the fairy
navigation system although this was
eventually shortened to the well-known
Zelda name of Navi after koizumi's wife
asked why there weren't any handsome
Nintendo characters the team redesigned
Adult Link a little bit but Miyamoto
didn't want link to be too cool so the
team added young Link to the game too
Ocarina of Time Is So beloved and iconic
that me talking about it could be its
own video from riding Epona over Hyrule
Fields vast planes the infamous and
beloved Dungeons and the game's clever
use of time it became the quintessential
Zelda game for a reason it was lauded by
critics and fans upon release with our
reviewer Jeff gerstman saying that it
manages to combine small aspects from
all the previous Zelda games giving you
the same Zelda feel but in an entirely
new way even in its huge fiercely 3D
World the game retains a truly classic
feel this is a sequel at its finest
expanding on previous themes and
bringing plenty of new stuff to the
table it currently sits as the number
one game of all time on Metacritic and
is commonly referred to as one of the
best video games ever made it's been
named as an inspiration for many game
developers including CD projekt Red and
from software a remake of Ocarina of
Time for the Nintendo 3DS was released
in 2011.
foreign
ER of time Nintendo had to think about
how to create a worthy follow-up over
the years game development had become
more and more expensive and with
PlayStation powering ahead with 3D games
the pressure was on Nintendo was
examining how they could repurpose their
existing games and assets one idea was
to release Master Quest a hard mode
unlocked by completing Ocarina of Time
onto the 64 Double D peripheral however
our pneumo who was tasked with
repurposing the game for its new form
quickly grew bored and began making new
dungeons he eventually asked Miyamoto if
he could make a new game and mimoto
agreed provided that it could be made
within a year elsewhere at Nintendo
koizumi was toying with a concept where
players would relive the same in-game
week over and over again koizumi agreed
to help aunuma out on the new Zelda
title if they could use the concept and
there Majora's mask's Innovative
three-day system was born
foreign
Majora's Mask a moon would fall and
destroy the world of termina using the
Ocarina link can play the song of time
and go back to the start of the cycle
and the player retains major items like
masks and weapons as well as knowledge
of upcoming events The Masks allow link
to transform into different creatures
with new abilities to Aid in puzzle
solving the clock counting down as you
explore the Twisted world of termina
added pressure to the game which had a
decidedly creepier tone than previous
Zelda titles it didn't sell as well as
Ocarina of Time but Majora's Mask still
received critical Acclaim when it
launched it was remade for the 3DS in
2015.
[Music]
in the late 90s Capcom developer yoshiki
okamoto set up a new studio named
Flagship funded by Capcom Sega and
Nintendo the studio worked on various
projects including Resident Evil 2 Co
Veronica and Dino Crisis 2. the team
eventually approached Nintendo to
suggest just porting the original Legend
of Zelda to the Game Boy Color
throughout the development process
however they realized that the game
needed modifications not only to run on
the handheld but to make it more
palatable to a modern audience after
speaking with Miyamoto the team instead
began working on a trio of
interconnected games called the Triforce
series The Three titles could be played
in any order and each focused on
different gameplay elements but by
completing all three you'd get the full
story this ended up being way too
complicated for the team to implement
and one game ended up being cut the
remaining two games were Oracle of
Seasons and Oracle of Ages it was and
remains rare for developers outside of
Nintendo to be tasked with developing a
Zelda game but the return to a top-down
2D Zelda and the Dual release approach
proved to be popular and the games were
a hit the games were similar to Link's
Awakening but link is transported to a
different world depending on which game
you're playing the other major
distinguishing Factor was a key weapon
that gave link a special ability Central
to the game mechanics in Oracle of
Seasons it was the rod of Seasons which
allows him to manipulate the seasons an
Oracle of Ages it was the harp of Ages
which allows link to travel through time
naturally both of these items were
critical to the game's combat Dungeons
and puzzles although it was yet another
experimental take on a Zelda game both
titles were critically and commercially
successful
at the Nintendo space World 2000 trade
show Nintendo showed off a demo that
offered a glimpse at what the Legend of
Zelda could look like on its upcoming
shiny new hardware the GameCube while
the link that was showed off looked like
a more graphically enhanced version of
the link from Ocarina of Time internally
the team decided to go in a completely
different direction a designer on the
team at yoshiki haruhana doodled what
would become known as Toon Link a boyish
cartoony version of the series hero from
there the team was immediately inspired
settling on the game's colorful
cell-shaded art style early on in its
development the team decided to set the
game at Sea with links sailing between
islands on his ship and controlling the
wind using the Wind Waker while the art
style proved divisive the game was a
critical success earning a rare 40 out
of 40 from famitsu and The Game of the
Year award from us Wind Waker is beloved
for introducing a version of link that
is much more expressive than his other
iterations Nintendo approached his
design with an almost comedic
sensibility which really enhanced the
animated movie Adventure Vibe of the
whole game toon Link's popularity would
also earn him a spot in future Smash
Brothers rosters an HD version of Wind
Waker was released for the Wii U in
2013. this version streamlined a number
of gameplay elements including a
particularly laborious End Game Quest
making it the definitive version of the
game
[Music]
in 2004 four Swords Adventures launched
for the GameCube and allowed up to four
players to take on the role of link and
Link's clones to work together to defeat
Shadow Link who has kidnapped the
maidens of various shrines a powerful
wizard named vati is also freed and a
dark dimension appears in Hyrule 2.
naturally all this eventually leads to
the Revelation that Ganon is up to his
old tricks again but four Swords
Adventure included a pretty involved
story for a multiplayer Zelda game it
also included a competitive multiplayer
mode where you fight against each other
in a bid to be the last one standing
multiplayer worked by connecting Game
Boy Advance consoles to the GameCube
using link cables and while critics
praised how well it worked not everyone
had a GameCube Game Boy Advance and the
required cables needed to play with
others
[Music]
the next handheld Zelda the Minish Cap
was once again developed by Flagship and
Capcom inspired by the NAT hat from four
Swords a key gameplay component was the
ability to shrink down to the diminutive
size of the Minish the game told the
story of the creation of the magical
weapon the fourth sword which allows
link to make up to three copies of
himself as we saw in the multiplayer for
swords games like Oracle of Ages and
Seasons Flagship and Capcom delivered
another beloved entry in the Zelda
series as Minish Cap is fondly
remembered for taking the fundamentals
of the series and coming up with
interesting new twists on them while the
game was criticized for its length
compared to many other Zelda experiences
it had enough fresh ideas to earn it a
spot in the hearts of Zelda fans
as first party support for the GameCube
was winding down Nintendo decided to
delay the release of its next Zelda game
Twilight Princess by a year so it could
launch with its upcoming console a
little thing called the Wii delaying the
release meant the team could polish the
game add more content and crucially for
the Wii version ensure that the motion
controls worked a fun tidbit is that in
Twilight Princess and later in Skyward
Sword link is right-handed despite being
shown as left-handed in the other games
this is to correspond with the fact that
most players would be right-handed
inspired by a dream where our Numa was a
wolf trapped in a Cell a key mechanic of
Twilight Princess is Link's ability to
transform into a wolf when he crosses
into the corrupted Twilight realm
interestingly this wouldn't be the only
Wolfgang to launch in 2006 as capcom's
Clover studio also released Okami and in
it you played as a wolf restoring peace
to a very colorful world but after the
colorful Capers of Wind Waker Twilight
Prince took the series to a more
realistic art style inspired by the
incredibly popular Lord of the Rings
movies Twilight Princess was an enormous
success in its opening week in North
America the company sold more than 600
000 Wii consoles three quarters of those
were sold with copies of Twilight
Princess an HD version of the game was
later released from the Wii U it
included a new dungeon as well as amiibo
support
foreign
[Applause]
console versions of Zelda were returning
to a more realistic aesthetic Zelda on
handheld retained the vibrant colorful
aesthetic of Wind Waker with its sequel
Phantom Hourglass for the Nintendo DS it
was heavily praised for making use of
the DS's touch controls with our
reviewer Alex Navarro saying that the
game implements its control mechanics so
seamlessly into the standard Zelda game
design that it's hard to imagine anyone
not appreciating it on some level
another widely praised feature was the
dungeon at the center of the game the
Temple of the ocean King which slowly
saps away at Link's Health while he's in
it only by acquiring a special item and
plenty more Hearts can you solve it
thank you
Spirit Tracks continued the Wind Waker
branch of the franchise and took players
from the sea back to land and explored
the concept of letting players Place
their own tracks and journey around
Hyrule in a cute little train the spirit
in Spirit Tracks however is poor
Princess Zelda who acts as your
companion throughout the game and who
can take control of enemy Phantoms you
can then control them to help you solve
puzzles in dungeons or attack nearby
enemies
foreign
[Music]
took us to the skies in 2011. in another
Wii title that's packed to the brim with
motion controlled movements after
implementing motion controls in Twilight
Princess the team began exploring how
the Wii Motion Plus device a peripheral
that would plug into a Wii mode to make
more precise and complex movements could
be utilized in a Zelda game turns out
with some difficulty as the team
struggled to tame the finicky add-on to
make it work for their purposes starting
from his home in the clouds the town of
skyloft Link hops on the back of a big
loftwing bird to get to where he needs
to go skyloft is surrounded by a number
of other floating islands all of which
have their own denizens to interact with
however link could also travel down to
the surface Overworld and this is where
a lot of the traditional adventuring
happens Skyward Sword also let players
Place beacons of light on a map which
they could then follow to their
objectives an idea that would later
return in breath of the wild Skyward
Sword also had significant narrative
implications as it is actually the first
game in the Zelda Canon and reveals the
story behind the creation of the iconic
Master Sword Skyward Sword is remembered
as a game that felt like it was caught
between trying to take risks and evolve
the Zelda franchise into something new
and exciting but also staying true to
the series Roots nevertheless it is
remembered fondly by fans and in the end
paved the way for what would end up
being a truly revolutionary Zelda title
Skyward Sword was remastered for the
Nintendo switch and released in July
A Link Between Worlds to the Nintendo
3DS didn't have the smoothest
development after Spirit Tracks had
launched many members of the team went
on to work on Skyward Sword with only
three left on a handheld Zelda project
initially the three pitched Miyamoto on
a game with the idea of communication
but it was shot down eventually the trio
came up with an idea where link could
enter walls and mimoto gave the team a
thumbs up to develop however they were
quickly pulled onto other projects to
help with the upcoming launch of
Nintendo's latest console the Wii U not
wanting their idea to be forgotten they
gave prototypes to Miyamoto tazuka and
ayanuma who ended up Reviving The
Project some years later A Link Between
Worlds takes place after the events of a
link to the past and involves our young
hero freeing Princess Zelda from the
clutches of an evil sorcerer named Yuga
as always yuga's plan is to use seven
sages to resurrect Ganon this time
around however link is equipped with a
magical bracelet that allows him to
merge into walls and become a
sticker-like version of himself to move
around world and reach previously
inaccessible areas it was a cool
mechanic that created very interesting
gameplay opportunities this was
reflected in the critical claim it
received with many reviews saying how
the merging mechanic elevated the
puzzles and dungeons of the game it also
sold very well
[Music]
Nintendo teamed up with grezo the studio
behind the Majora's Mask and Ocarina of
Time 3DS ports for Triforce Heroes a
Cooperative handheld Adventure which
sadly didn't set the world on fire our
review criticized the dungeons for being
repetitive and the game's weak story but
praised its loot system and Cooperative
modes but if that was one week Link in
the list of Mainline Zelda games then
the next game would be a genre defining
Masterpiece originally due to launch in
2015 for the Wii U two years later
Nintendo released breath of the wild
timing it with the release of its brand
new console the Nintendo switch after
hearing criticisms about the more linear
nature of recent Zelda releases the team
opted to make breath of the Wild open
world with a loose plot of defeat Ganon
by rounding up four Divine beasts and
the Champions who pilot them players
could approach the adventure however
they wanted the large open world is
littered with places of interest
dungeons to best enemy groups to defeat
and of course puzzles to solve and
secrets to find
in almost every respect the breath of
the wild felt like a modernization of
the Zelda franchise and in a few ways
set the standard for how open World
Games could be designed going forward
after flirting with the open-natured
structure in numerous other titles
Nintendo finally committed to letting
the player chart their own path and the
impact that had on the overall
experience was revolutionary link was no
longer tethered so Strictly To The
Ground as he could now scale pretty much
any surface which introduced an
unprecedented verticality to the game
and made exploration itself a major
puzzle well-worn design ideas such as
towers that uncover a map were given New
Life in breath of the wild which chose
to tell the player very little about
what was actually around the world and
instead tasked them with discovering it
for themselves combat was also
revolutionized becoming more open to
expression along with traditional items
like the sword shield bombs and bow and
arrows link gained special abilities
such as freezing certain objects and
enemies in place with damage dealt to
whatever ever was in stasis stacking
along with any other physics-based
effects coupled with the ability to LEAP
higher impact movement with items and
weapons and breath of the wild combat
became a playground of possibilities an
entire Community has grown around
discovering the outlandish things you
can do with the mechanics of the game
and you only have to take a look at the
videos created by our very own bona fide
breath of the wild expert Max to see
just how Wild it can get the game
launched two Universal critical Acclaim
with tens across the board from most
major gaming Outlets needless to say
breath of the wild put Zelda On A New
Path and it's one that is poised to take
the franchise to even greater Heights
with its next entry foreign
which brings us to tears of the Kingdom
although breath of the wild had DLC the
team had big ideas that they could only
Implement by making another game like
Skyward Sword tears of the Kingdom has
Islands floating above the ground
introducing a whole new dimension of
exploration to the sequel link will also
now have expanded and new abilities like
fuse which can bind objects together to
create new weapons and recall which
reverses time for a targeted object
expectations are high for tears of the
kingdom and will know soon enough where
the link and Nintendo can rise to meet
them thanks for watching it's gonna be
an exciting week here on Gamespot
because we have new shows premiering
every single day tomorrow Kurt is going
to be taking a look at why there are so
many remakes Dave Klein is going to be
looking at how Resident Evil 4 saved the
Resident Evil franchise John Luke's
going to tell you how to get the best
out of remake and we also have a brand
new new show with me and Tam where we
discuss all of the biggest issues in the
gaming industry we'll also have a sword
expert take a look at Jedi Survivor and
the return of firearms expert reacts Now
to celebrate we are going to be giving
away a lot of prizes including copies of
brand new games like red form Jedi
Survivor and even a PlayStation 5. this
is open to us residents only if you want
to be in with a chance of winning make
sure to check the pinned comment below